c'est une romance gothique donc ce que ce n'est pas
n'est pas un film d'horreur c'est une
romance gothique et il y a une grande différence
ce n'est pas un film de maison hantée
c'est une romance gothique aussi une grande
différence je pense que la façon de l'
illustrer est un film de maison hantée fait le
le mal de la maison et une romance gothique font de
la maison une représentation de la
folie ou de la décadence des personnages
ce n'est pas une histoire de fantômes mais un fantôme un
film avec un fantôme dedans vous savez donc
c'est vraiment l'essence de la romance gothique
c'est le mariage de l'amour  et la mort et
l'idée qu'il y a des ténèbres dans l'amour
et qu'il y a de la romance dans la mort les
fantômes sont réels je les ai vus toute ma
vie en
premier je n'aurais jamais imaginé que c'est ce que
vous faites
Je viens de fantômes ne sont pas
à prendre à la légère Je comprends sa
fascination pour Edith de Sharpe
c'est ma sœur mais procédez avec prudence j'ai l'
impression qu'elle le lien existe entre
votre cœur et le mien il s'agit du
voyage d'un  jeune femme qui
tombe amoureuse et découvre que l'homme qu'elle
aime est plus complexe qu'il n'y
parait au début Je joue Edith qui est
ouais
une jeune femme elle est très ambitieuse une
jeune écrivaine ambitieuse et très curieuse
et fougueuse au début mais
aussi assez idéaliste et je
tombe même donc en quelque sorte amoureuse
du personnage de Tom et se retrouve dans
cette dynamique familiale très étrange est-ce que
quelqu'un est mort dans cette maison des morts spécifiques des
morts violentes
c'est un film sur les secrets et les
secrets du passé et comment ils se
rattrapent  avec vous et ils vous hantent et la
maison elle-même semblait avoir tellement
d'ombres et tellement de
coins magnifiquement détaillés que les gens ne
pourront pas le voir mais juste pour nous le mot
peur
les lettres f.e.a.r were ont été gravées
dans le papier peint  et l'ascenseur
fonctionnait sur trois étages et lee
feuilles d'automne à quatre à travers le plafond
c'était vraiment à couper le souffle la maison aussi vieille
que celle-ci devient avec le temps une
chose vivante commence  s'accrocher à des choses
certaines bonnes certaines sont mauvaises certaines ne devraient plus
jamais être évoquées
que voulez-vous